indica is with us in Kansas hi indica
how are you I'm alright thank you for
having me sure what's up so I I'm 43
years old my husband is 39 and we've
been married for 16 years now and the
entire time it's been a bit of a
struggle and this last year's a little
bit more because we've done stupid
things and managed to you know get into
debt and we make about eighty-five
thousand a year after taxes and I know
it's doable I just need to sit him down
and get him on board which I was getting
ready to do except his mom passed rather
quickly it was a cancer diagnosis and
within about three weeks it was all kind
of rushed in she was gone so part of
this is also now his dad who is 74 is in
a huge financial hole they've been
behind on bills payments and we're
trying to figure out what to do with him
cause he does have some medical issues
they live about three hours from us and
there is some conversation my brother
has an older brother who's 10 years his
senior that because of his dad's doctors
being somewhat closer if they move up to
Kansas City area that there's some talk
of having him move here I love him to
death
but I am also extremely scared that if
he moves up here and lives with us I see
us in the hole they were in because
Buddha's take on a lot more financial
responsibility and mental stress of it I
know I work from home quite a bit we'll
probably end up getting me um to be
completely honest I'm not really sure
I'll manage can't survive all of those
stresses at the same time I'm trying to
figure out the right time cuz I know
he's grieving and he has depression so
I'm trying to figure out
the right time to bring up you know hey
let's let's do Dave's plan get let's put
ourselves on the budget how long how
long ago this mom pass it's been about
not even a month it's only been three
weeks so it's very recent so it's a lot
of emotion well let's let's just kind of
back up a second I mean there's no
you've been you've been doing this wrong
for 16 years 16 more days is not going
to make a difference as long as you
don't allow it to get worse and that's
you acquiescing to dad moving in in the
middle of all this emotion okay so how
old is dad he is 74
he had kind of health issue yen he is oh
well he's had stroke multiple heart
attacks bypasses he has very bad
short-term memory issues so one of the
big concerns is like he'll forget to
take his medication so I think I think
it's you know I think you can just let
this sit for a minute okay um just to
give yourself a minute give your husband
a minute he's grieving he's got a lot of
stuff on plate a lot of concerns for his
dad the only reason you would need to
raise the subject today would be to
prevent your father-in-law from moving
in with you and he does not need to move
in with you okay I yeah it's better than
mine you don't bring it up though okay
if it gets brought up deal with it
but it's not gonna you know just let
them work through their emotions and
their options him and his brother and
his dad and and let the thing land
without you having to take a stand that
is unnecessary very possibly which would
be further alienating to your husband
just let it sit pray for your husband
pray for his dad let them have some time
to heal and
let them work through this if they ask
you what your opinion is you can give it
but I really wouldn't inject yourself
into this and just just let this thing
work itself out over the next month or
two it's going to work itself out over
the next month or two that's my
prediction I think the chances of them
recommending him moving in with you is
very very low if they do then you're
gonna have to say no our marriage is not
strong enough I'm not emotionally strong
enough and we're not financially strong
enough to endure him being here and so
I'm not going to go along with that
we're not doing that because I care too
much about my marriage and my future and
the best way we can help him is for us
to get strong over here and him coming
in it's not going to do that it's going
to further weaken us we're not in a
position to the only way you can help
someone that's hurting is you have to be
stronger than they are and you guys
aren't that makes sense absolutely okay
and then you start to work on your
marriage and your money and you say you
know we're gonna start the seeing a
marriage counselor when you said sixteen
years we've been struggling where you're
saying financially struggling or
maritally struggling multi financial
we're all very happy yeah and we it's
really not been that bad financially
until maybe the last four or five and
then there's a marriage issue because
you said I don't think my marriage will
survive him moving in that doesn't say
you've got a good marriage that says you
have a bad marriage right hey my
marriage can survive people moving into
my house I'm not gonna let them anyway
but but it could survive it you know
okay so it's that that's the thing so
you know when you make a statement like
that you're saying things about your
situation out loud it's okay
we've all been there and so let him have
a little time to heal and grieve his mom
and work through some options for his
dad when the smoke clears on that then
it'll be time to address your marriage
and your money issues and I'd start
seeing a marriage counselor and get in
Financial Peace University
we all need to have new information to
have a new future what got us here what
got us here won't get us there and if
you keep doing the same thing over and
over again expecting a different result
we call that the definition of insanity
don't we so you know and the same thing
sir I mean Sharon and I you know after
we've been married about 10 years we you
know it's about four years after our
bankruptcy we had a delayed PTSD effect
on our marriage we about killed each
other during the bankruptcy and then
suddenly about four years later we both
killed each other again it's like it
popped back up you know and that's when
we landed in the marriage counselors
office and she saved our lives because
we were we were don't kill each other I
mean it was ridiculous I mean because
Hillbillies don't just fight we fight at
a different level you know and so um you
know it's okay to need coaching on
something we needed tools we didn't have
you need some tools you don't have
relational tools and money tools agreed
agreed no shame in that
that's not condemnation that's just you
and me we're on the same journey I'm
just a little further down the path as
all and so yeah get but but give him
some room and cuz if you pick a fight
that doesn't need to be fought you're
and do more damage than you need to just
just let this heal it's probably gonna
work itself out I'm gonna give you a 90%
probability they do not recommend he
move in with you guys because I think
deep down your husband doesn't really
want him to either that's my guess so
hey if we can help you further you call
us anytime that's what we're here for
kiddo
you're going to get through this and the
point is through it